on s'installe on a moins de temps que
d'habitude bonjour Morel merci d'être
avec nous meilleur V très très belle
année et on attend Michel darmond qui va
nous rejoindre éditorialiste politique
on va parler surprise des marché de Noël
ouais par je sais que ça va vous manquer
ça il a plein d'autres choses Quentin
pour vous vous allez voir on va parler
du gouvernement de Gabriel à T resserrée
et cap à droite avec notamment la
surprise rachidti Benjamin vous nous
direz quels enseignements on peut tirer
de ce nouveau gouvernement et cette
nomination de Gabriel qu on va parler
des entrants mais pas que voilà il y a
des enseignements politiques attirés
effectivement de l'équilibre politique
de ce nouveau gouvernement avec les
entran qu'on note mais également en
regardant bien les sortants de ce
gouvernement on voit ça dans quelques
instants et on parle évidemment de ce
remanement c'est à la Une de nombreux de
nombre de vos quotidiens régionaux ce
matin on voit ça tout de
[Musique]
suite et la Une de plusieurs de vos
quotidiens régionaux ce matin c'est la
nomination du gouvernement de Gabriel
hatal pour en parler on va aller
direction wapi c'est à côté de MESS on
retrouve Hervé bot bonjour Hervé merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous chef du
service reportage au Républicain Laurent
Hervé à la Une de votre journal ce matin
ce gouvernement à tal et de nombreuses
pages sont à lire dans Le Républicain
Lauren sur ces nominations
oui absolument on consacre de pages et
demi à la formation du gouvernement de
de gabrielal dans la opposition a été
annoncée pour l'essentiel hier en fin de
journée même si on attend des
nominations complémentaires dans dans
les jours qui viennent nous l'avez dit
un gouvernement resserré 11 ministre toi
ministre délégué pour l'heure euh et qui
ben en l'état et surtout moins
exemplaire peut-être sur le sur le plan
de la parité quatre femmes seulement
parmi les ministres de de plein exercice
et puis une coloration vous l'avez noté
aussi Qui est qui est nettement à droite
Sarkozi même disent certains certains
observateurs alors surtout un
gouvernement qui qui vu de messe va à
nos yeux une caractéristiques
supplémentair il ne compte qu'une seule
ministre issue du Grand T la Rémoise
Catherine Vautrin même si le
portefeuille du travail de la santé et
des solidarités fusionné la place à la
tête de de ce qu'on commence déjà à
appeler un des des super ministère de ce
de ce gouvernement euh en ce qui
concerne plus spécifiquement la Lorine
et ben après la la sortie du du
gouvernement de du mdecin François Brown
l'été
dernier le sort de l'anoncienne Carole
Rangan qui était jusqu'alors ministre
délégué à l'enseignement à la formation
professionnelle elle semble en suspent
en tout cas elle n'a pas été pour le
moment cité alors cette composition a
bien sûr en Lorine suscité nombre de de
réactions vous l'imaginez bien commencé
par par celle du député renaissance de
de laamiselle par exemple Ludovic mendz
qui lui continue à voir dans dans la
nomination de de Gabriel Atal un coup
d'audace absolument salutaire du
président de la République et ne formule
aucune objection quant à la constitution
de d'un gouvernement extrêmement serré
au contraire là où où les critiques bah
sur ces super ministères justement
commencent commencent déjà à fuser à
l'exemple de de celui de du ministère de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports de de Madame oué à casterra B
Ludovic mendz lui il note que fusionner
portefeuille c'est pas une pratique tout
à fait nouvelle d'abord he ça c'est déjà
fait et dans des gouvernements de droite
comme de gauche et puis bah il soulligne
les les liens de cohérence qui peuvent
exister dans entre ces entre ces
différents portefeuilles Bertrand
Pancher également le le député de la
Meuse qui est aussi président du groupe
lot à l'Assemblée
euh qui qui lui pour pour sa part euh a
simplement souligné que en fait c'était
pas d'un remanement que que que la
France avait besoin mais bien d'un
nouveau cap et qui qui fustige le le
choix d'un d'un d'un Premier ministre
qui sans sans expérience de terrain est
très est très parisien euh au-delà de ça
côté nupes par exemple pas de réaction
réellement spécifique en tout cas pour
le moment ex cétait Martine Étienne la
député de de loui en meurtmosel qui qui
a relayé hier un poste de manuel bonpard
qui bah qui fustigé le fait que
Gabrielle Atal je cite he n'avait pas
souvent été confronté aux difficultés de
la vie puisqu'il avait passé en grande
partie la sienne dans les 6e et 7e
arrondissement de Paris sera les gens
appréciés côté LR avec la nomination de
Rachid Alati qui a beaucoup fait parler
finalement c'est les réactions restent
relativement à tonne et thibo Bazin qui
qui sur le le même réseau x s'est
contenté de
de relayer un un poste où Rachid hadti
donnait il y a quelques temps sa
définition de du macronisme la phrase
est tourne en boucle depuis hier à parti
de trait de gauche et de traître de
droite qui n'est rien sans Emmanuel
Macron et enfin le le député de
laamoiselle porte-parole du du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
Laurent jacobelli lui bah pour le coup
il va pas avec le avec le dos de la
cuillère hier sur X également il a il a
qualifié ce ce nouveau gouvernement en
expliquant que c'était les PI niclés qui
remplaçaient les chadoc là aussi on
appréciera mais pour enfoncer le clou il
a lu aussi rappeler les propos de de de
Rachid adati sur les traîtres avant de
souligner qu'en fait bah la seule
question que qui se posait c'est est-ce
que Gabriel Atal pourra demain prendre
les bonnes mesures et bah cette question
il répond par la négative en expliquant
que pas plus hier qu'aujourd'hui ce
dernier là de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour soutenir les réformes à
venir merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous à lire ce matin dans Le Républicain
Laurin les ténors rest rachidti arrivve
c'est c'est le titre que vous avez
choisi pour résumer ce gouvernement à T
merci beaucoup merci bio d'avoir été
avec nous Michael daron est arrivé
bonjour Michel merci d'être là
éditorialiste politique merveux à vous
Michel on va parler de ce gouvernement
un gouvernement Quentin qui penche
nettement à droite voilà il y a
effectivement des poids lourds qui
étaient déjà là et installés qui venait
deslr et et bien ils sont confirmés
comme Bruno Le Maire Gérald daranin ou
encore Sébastien le cor nuU ce sont des
ministres maintenus qui font que et bien
de facto avec ces trois ministres que
vous voyez sur la gauche et bien
l'équilibre était déjà qui sont à droite
oui
pardon c'est ça les ministres à gauche
sur cette animation mais qui viennent
der RLR je crois que j'avais dit une
bêtise et donc il y en a encore d'autres
DLR parmi les entrants on pense bien sûr
et on vient on vient d'en parler on
pense à la mère du 7e arrondissement
Rachid adati qui rentre rue de Valois à
la culture elle a été ministre on le
rappelle de Nicolas Sarkozi entre 2007
et 2009 à la justice desésier le parti
allire a d'ailleurs annoncé que rachti
jeess de se placer en dehors de sa
famille politique en entrant au
gouvernement autre personnalité
Catherine Vautrin l'ancienne députée
présidente de la métropole de reince
hérite voilà d'un super ministère c'est
comme cela qu'il faut le dire
effectivement alors elle était déjà donc
avec le travail santé solidarité elle
était déjà ministre en charge de la
cohésion sociale de la parité entre 2005
et 2007 c'était sous Dominique de
Villepin alors depuis hier les syndicats
sont dubitatifs à la CFTC on estime que
travail et santé méritait de ministères
de plein exercice et un syndicat de
médecin également interrogé par l'Agence
France Presse a eu cette expression hier
est-ce que cette nomination est le signe
que la santé est un sujet très important
méritant un grand ministère ou bien
est-ce que c'est le signe que ne mérite
pas un ministère à part entière par le
passé on le rappelle Xavier Bertrand et
Martine Aubri ont déjà occupé deux
grands ministères tête de grands
ministères avec santé et travail
ensemble ouais avant de revenir sur le
gouvernement qui penche à droite
effectivement c'est aussi l'une des
questions de ce gouvernement c'est que
c'est un gouvernement resserré avec des
grands ministères qui ont donc des
grands intitulés et c'est vrai qu'il y a
des critiques sur le fait que à la fois
l'école et à la fois la santé qui sont
deux préoccupation majeure des Français
se retrouve un peu noyé oui alors cette
affaire de gouvernement resserré c'est
souvent je dirais un artifice de cor les
présidents de la République les premier
ministres adorent dire on a une équipe
resserrée ça fait bien dans l'opinion
c'est très discutable du point de vue du
fonctionnement de l'État pour deux
raisons si vous voulez tenir votre
administration et ben avoir des grands
grands ministères souvent ça ne marche
pas vous avez besoin justement du
politique pour arriver à impulser de la
décision l'autre élément et bien c'est
que un grand ministère ça veut dire pas
beaucoup de ministères et pas beaucoup
de ministères si vous regardez la 5e
République plus votre majorité est
divisée plus votre majorité est fragile
plus votre majorité est rétrécie plus
vos gouvernements sont plétor pourquoi
parce que donner des strapontins
ministériaux ministériels ça permet de
donner des gages et donc ça solidifie
votre majorité donc là on en reparlera
sans doute c'est plus une un
gouvernement de combat pour les
européennes que vraiment un gouvernement
pour tenir la majorité ensuite il va
quand même falloir voir les ministres
délégués les secrétaires d'État l'aspect
administratif que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure voilà l'aspect administratif que
j'ai évoqué vous pouvez quand même
arriver à tenir votre administration en
ayant comme ça un dispatchage ensuite
mais vous donnez l'apparence d'un
gouvernement resserré à avec derrière et
bien des effectifs plétoriques ça peut
poser ensuite d'autres soucis de
cohérence mais en effet ça fait que
malgré tout vous tenez un peu mieux les
choses si ça reste en l'état en effet ce
serait très problématique ouais est-ce
que politiquement Michel c'est si bien
joué que ça d'avoir ces grands
ministères qui fait que certains sujet
majeur se retrouve un peu noyé ce qui
suscite évidemment quelques critiques
oui ça suscite des critiques on vient de
les entendre elles sont effectivement
justifié l'autre argument et
vraisemblablement c'est ce qu'il est
emporté c'est de faire de de l'affichage
politique
c'est afficher donc une une équipe faite
d'incarnation il faut bien savoir quand
même que ça fait quelques temps que les
Français ne connaissent que trois ou
quatre ministres de toute façon pour eux
le gouvernement est déjà très resserré
dans leur esprit depuis très longtemps
donc de ce point de vue là il y a la
volonté de dire alors que on bascule
dans la partie électorale du quinquena
avec joint les élections européennes
puis les élections locales qui
arriveront et ensuite bien sûr la
présidentielle donc de ce point de vu-là
là il faut refaire la politique et il
est clair que on
passe forme une période les experts
disent une forme de
glaciation politique à une mant une
période de réchauffement avec cette
équipe qui bien évidemment Gabriel Atal
rachadti en tête vont donner une
nouvelle impulsion et un nouveau je
dirais pô parce qu'il y a maintenant des
enjeux politiques qui sont effectivement
très présents face au gouvernement il
n'y a pas de changement de cap
gouvernemental mais il y a la volonté de
chercher un nouveau souffle en revanche
du point de vue de l'action et de
l'impact politique c'est c'est aussi ça
qu'on qu'on retient de ce gouvernement
exite la société civile c'est le retour
du politique au manette oui c'est le
retour du politique et c'est le retour
et c'est je suis absolument d'accord
c'est le retour des incarnation parce
que si vous voulez exister politiquement
il faut des personnalités que vous
connaissez et le choix de rachidti il
est multifactoriel évidemment mais c'est
également ça c'est-à-dire que comme
nagerre le choix du pontoretti en
réalité lors du maniment avec éc Moretti
vous avez en fait une grande permanence
ça bouge pas beaucoup mais tout le monde
retient que quand même là il s'est passé
un truc il y a quelqu'un qu'on connaît
qui est rentré au gouvernement idem ici
et donc forcément ça ça vous donne un
espace politique ça vous donne une
ouverture ça vous donne et bien quelque
chose qui vous permet de mordre sur
l'opinion donc on rentre en effet dans
une phase qui est une phase d'abord et
avant tout électorale le remaniement
d'hier il est pas cohérent du point de
vue de la gestion de la majorité
parlementaire exite la gauche alors
qu'il y en a besoin alors qu'on a 30 à
50 députés qui pevent être rture de Ban
le modem à mon avis François Baou doit
être entin délicatesse Édouard Philippe
fair il a quand même un gage mais malgré
tout la nomination de gabar lu a pas
beaucoup plus je pense donc on a quand
même une majorité vant et horizon
exactement on a quand même une majorité
qui ne va pas être plus unis après ce
remanement mais en revanche si
l'objectif c'est d'être en ordre de
bataille pour les européennes avec des
communiquants avec des puncherss et bien
en effet à ce moment-là c'est un
remanimement qui s'explique c'est un
remanement qui est cohérent vaenir
Quentin sur la le retour du politique
oui ça fait quand même ça donne une
impression que le président la
République aurait acté la fin de ce
nouveau monde qu'il avait prené en 2017
rappelez-vous quand il avait dit au
députés lrem la République en marche à
l'époque qu'il fallait qu'il soit fier
d'être des amateurs sous entendu que
leur innocence en politique ou le fait
qu'ils étaient nouveau en politique ça
devait être un un gage voilà comme cela
de de qualité on voit qu'il y a
maintenant il va à rebour de cette idée
quelques années plus tard donc ça ça
acte quand même un changeement dans la
macronie ouais ce remignement un
changement et aussi le fait d'assumer
une tendance qui a commencé dès 2017 on
voit bien maintenant que le le le en
même temps n'était qu'un paravant en
réalité l'objectif était de fracturer la
droite on est maintenant tout près de
cette d'avoir atteint pouruel Macron
cette C cet objectif effectivement
Gabriel Atal il fait l'ouverture
jusqu'au sarkoziis pour reprendre
l'expression de de d'gité Patrick de et
de ce point de vuel on voit bien qu'il y
a une une période qui changeel Macron
assume le fait d'être maintenant un
président quasiment de droite il a
commencé quand même en parlant de
startup nation en parlant de de nouveau
monde et depuis quelques temps les
maîtres mot c'est décivilisation l'ordre
la sécurité on est on est clairement
là-dessus et Gabriel est celui qui
incarne plus il était au porte-parole je
me rappelle du gouvernement un jour
m'avit dit au fond nous avons changé
d'électorat en cours de quinquena nous
sommes maintenant sur la droite et il
est celui qui incarne le mieux cette
mutation de de justement de je dirais la
culture politique des des des
macronistes en particulier ceux qui sont
au gouvernement et face à la à la
demande sociale aujourd'hui qui
évidemment tend beaucoup plus vers la
droite Benjamin ce gouvernement il est
le reflet de la sociologie électorale
d'Emmanuel Macron oui mais c'est quand
même un par un Paris dangereux la
sociologie électorale d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est quoi en deux mots en 2017 c'est 2
tiers gauche un tiers droite centre
gauche centre droit à partir de 2019
c'est très précoce dans le quinena le
premier quinena c'est 2/ers droite un
tiers gauche le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que pour Emmanuel Macron ce Paris
tout à droite il peut être relativement
dangereux parce que il prendra pas on a
beaucoup dit Gabriel Atal et l'arme anti
Bardella du point de vue de l'image et
cetera ça permet de créer en effet un
duopole mais il ira chercher aucun
électeur à Jordane Bardella votre
principal adversaire en politique c'est
pas celui qui est votre opposé c'est
ceux à qui vous pouvez piquer des voies
et donc en l'occurrence France soit
Xavier bami mais également et bien les
listes de la gauche Raphael guusman les
ver et cetera là si jamais vous avez un
gouvernement qui polarise trop à droite
vous pouvez aller chercher des électeurs
NR mais vous risquez de perdre sur votre
gauche et donc ce faisant quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui l'espace résiduel
qui qui reste au républicains il y a pas
tant que ça encore à aller chercher
François Xavier béami la dernière fois
qui fait fait plutôt une bonne campagne
he tout le monde lui est tombé dessus en
disant oui c'est de sa faute et cetera
en réalité tout le monde quelques
semaines avant disait plutôt cette
campagne est dynamique mais mais la
réalité c'est que et bien vous avez un
effet des taux et qu'à partir de là dans
le casadre de cet effet des taux vous
avez un vote utile pour Bardella ou pour
à l'époque natal l'oiseau d'une partie
de cet électorat droite donc les
réserves de voie dans cet espace LR sont
aujourd'hui très très limité alleer
faire le Paris d'aller chercher encore
des voies dans cet espace en prenant le
risque en fragilisant votre aile gauche
c'est un Paris qui est un Paris qui peut
s'entendre et c'est un Paris que demain
la majorité pourrait quand même payer
toujours lors de ces élections
européennes ouais on va parler des
européennes mais est-ce que ça entré de
rachti au gouvernement ça peut être le
coupt fatal pour les républicains Michel
en tout cas c'est un coup très dur
c'était quand même c'est une
personnalité qui occupait des des des
postes dans dans les hautes instances
des
républicains on diffuse tous toutes les
toutes les voilà toutes les les
professions de foi qu'elle faisait
vis-à-vis de LR vis-à-vis d'éc cotti et
la manière dont elle traitait et
fustigit le parti en marche encore il
n'y a pas si longtemps c'est aussi
paradoxal c'estàdire que au l'objectif
on voit bien est de liquider de de tuer
l'air de siphonner l'air mais en même
temps dirais une des premières l'attente
de ce nouveau gouvernement c'est de
savoir si l'engagement écrit d'Élizabeth
borne fait à la droite si ricioti de
réformer laame va être tenu parce que
c'est ce qui est très très attendu
évidemment au sein de au sein de de de
du Parlement au sein àroit c'est l'enjeu
également pour un Gabriel at de pouvoir
parfois sur des textes à des LR et c'est
aussi en phase avec une demande une
partie d'opinion en tout cas que à
laquelle veut parler ce nouveau
gouvernement donc parti du de avec l du
projet immigration ça un engagement
ferme pris à
ce estce que Gabri se sentir engagé il
s'est senti engagé par l'emploi du temps
en allant pas de calis dès la nomination
est-ce qu'il se sera sentira engagé par
la lettre vis-à-vis de de l'accord sur
lesimmigration Benj je peux pas répondre
à la place de Gabriel en revanche il est
certain que cette affaire va pas non
plus soigner les relations avec les LR
c'est-à-dire que évidemment LR a
toujours été un groupe d'opposition et
de toute façon on a vu au moment de la
réforme des retraites que passer un deal
avec LR avec les chefs de lrah n'aidait
pas forcément le gouvernement parce que
le groupe LR à l'assemblée était trop
divisé mais là il y a deux épreuves il y
a l'épreuve Rachid hadti et donc face ça
forcément ça peut être pris comme une
mauvaise façon après quand même LR qui
est venu au secours et de la réforme des
retraites et qui a imposé sa loi sur la
loi immigration et de autre côté et bien
on va avoir la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de la loi immigration là
non plus je peux pas parler à la place
de Laurent fabus on pe quand même penser
que cette décision elle va être
sacrément salée et qu' y a quand même
pas mal de dispositions qui devrai
sauter ce qui risque également bah de
fâcher un petit peu dans les rang de LR
même c'est quand même très très
prévisible et qu'il le savait et donc on
risque d'avoir et un groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale mais également une
droite sinatoriale qui risque d'être un
peu moins bien disposé durant les
prochains mois d'autant que les était
enfin semblait en tout cas plutôt
bienveillant dans les premières heures
de la nomination de Gabriel hatal il
disait attendre les actes avant de le
juger est-ce que là ça peut changer la
donne du coup oui j'étais bienveillant
parce que c'est vrai que il a su leur
parler et peut-être aussi il était
peut-être conscient du
danger en coulisse du côté de LR on sait
très bien queémanuel Macron ve la
liquider hein donc de ce point de vue-là
il y avait aussi des propos qui étaient
un peu des des des jeux de rôle ce à
quoi on assiste au fond c'est une
répétition du scénario des régional
dernières élections régionales quand on
a vu des ténors de de la du Sud de la
droite du Sud venir rejoind de la
macronie pour pouvoir gagner des des
collectivités notamment Ren Muselier
prés Ren Muselier avec également donc
Christian estrzi et Hubert Falco on voit
bien que et on comprend D et déjà parce
que d'ailleurs elle le dit elle-même
sans ambage l'ancienne maire du 7è
arrondissement que il s il s'est répété
ce deal également vis-à-vis de la Mairie
de Paris il y a fort à parier que au
fond il y ait un accord en tout cas
c'est ce que l'on entend très très
clairement un accord entre Emmanuel
Macron et rachtif pour ensuite le
soutien d'une candidature et tête de
liste LR majorité présidentielle pour
pour la mairie de Paris en 2006 donc
mais du coup est-ce que est-ce qu'cti a
bien fait de l'exclure immédiatement
est-ce que c'est bien joué poliquement
il n'a pas d'autre choix que de que de
manifester le peu d'autorité qui lui
reste est-ce que s'il peut y avoir
d'autres Alair parce que là on a eu la
première partie du gouvernement mais il
y aura encore de de nombreux ministres
et secrétaires d'État est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à à d'autres débuches vous
entendez franc Louvrier maire de La
Baule ancien dirigeant de la
communication Nicolas Sarkozi compagnon
de roue de Nicolas Sarkozi sur les ondes
depuis hier soir dire à quel point
rachidti a raison d'avoir rejoint le
gouvernement on peut penser
effectivement qu'il peut y avoir il
pourrait y avoir il y a encore 3 ans il
y aura encore des remaniements il peut y
avoir encore d'autres d'autres échéances
de de de ce style mais ce que l'on ce à
quoi on insiste aussi c'est que au fond
Nicolas Sarkozi et comme Madame Dati ont
plaidé en permanence pour avoir un
accord avec la droite cet accord n'est
pas formalisé mais il est quand
même viabilisé on va dire par par ce ce
ce ce transfert parce queeffectivement
cela cela incarne et ça permet à à
Emmanuel Macron de dire je reviens à
l'esprit 2017 c'est-à-dire au débauchage
important de la droite souvenez-vous
Bruno Lemaire Édouard Philippe Gérald
armanin qui euh voilà franchissait le
Rubicon il avaiit perdu les élections
présidentielles et il passait du côté du
vainqueur on assiste peu au prou à ce
scénario qui se répète oui mais ça reste
des individualités c'est-à-dire que on
voit qu'actuellement de toute façon LR
est trop divisé pour que le débauchage
de telle ou telle individualité quel que
soit ce qu'elle peut peser dans
l'opinion quel que soit même ce qu'elle
pourrait peser dans le parti et ben
n'est pas suffisant pour de manière
organique construire une majorité ou
arriver à construire des unions par
ailleurs il va y avoir une question qui
qui va se poser assez rapidement après
les européenes il commence déjà à se
poser qui est la question de l'après et
donc là si jamais vous avez une
candidature dynamique qui émerge dans le
sein de la majorité présidentielle
évidemment ça drainera des figures de la
droite si la candidature dynamique
arrive hors de la majorité
présidentielle et bien ça drainera
probablement des figure de la macronie
hors de la macronie donc là on a quand
même une épreuve très darwinienne avec
l'impossibilité du président de se
représenter qu'Emmanuel Macron essae de
repousser le plus loin possible d'où le
fait de parier sur les Européennes de
pas dire on remanira pas après et on
verra d'essayer de gagner ces
européennes ou de moins de ne pas y être
totalement humilié pour que ça continue
à tenir et que les grenouilles reste
encore dans la même brouette pour citer
François Baou don a parlé dans quelques
instants oui c'est on sent bien que un
des perdants quand même effectivement
par rapport à ses perspectives et bien
c'est à ce stade Édouard Philippe qui se
trouve voilà barré on on entend la la
colère de de François Baayou on verra
jusqu'où elle ira concrètement pour
l'instant il est quand même voilà il
fait savoir son son son mécontentement
on a effectivement un Nicolas un je
dirais un Emmanuel Macron qui lui au
fond reprend reprend le profil qui lui
est connu en tout cas confirme le profil
qui lui est connu c'est-à-dire que il il
agit selon selon son intérêt et comme
disent les les gens qui l'ont connu de
l'époque aussi où il était banquier
d'affair il vous il ne vous donne pas
l'heure on va on a parlé des entrants on
va aussi parler des sortant en tout cas
pour le moment Quentin parce que ça dit
aussi peut-être beaucoup de choses
politiquement voilà le gouvernement qui
perd quasiment toutes ces figures venu
de la gauche dans la liste des ministres
sortants Olivier du sopte Olivier
verérrand Clément bon Olivier duopte
Olivier verrant il venait même du Parti
socialiste et Clément bon il était
clairement identifié se revendiquer
comme l'aile gauche de la macronie alors
effectivement on le rappelle il y aura
une deè salve de nomination de
ministrees donc ces équilibres peuvent
encore évoluer on verra si il y a de
nouveaux entrants qui viennent plus de
cette aile gauche et on verra également
la réaction on en parlait du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale qui
dispose d'une aile gauche qui s'était
fait entendre lors du projet de loi
immigration au mois de décembre dernier
ouais et et pour Clément bon qui était
mis délégué il peut peut-être espérer
que son son sort n'est n'est pas encore
scellé mais quand même il y a un signal
Olivier dusopte c'est acté il perd son
ministère Olivier verérrand pareil
qu'est-ce qu' a voulu signifier Emmanuel
Macron politiquement que il tenait plus
compte de l'ail gauche il misait sur la
droite oui on sent bien que il est il
donne quand même kitus il entend il est
beaucoup plus sensible à cette son
appelle rapidement euh les droits la
droitisation de de la société cette
demande du corps social d'être sur des
des sujets lié aussi principalement à la
à la sécurité à l'autorité céit sur ce
sujet-là que Gabriel Atal a construit sa
récente grande popularité c'est sur les
actes d'autorité au sein de euh
lorsqu'il était ministre de de l' de
l'éducation nationale lorsque seulement
pardon il a fait il a l'interdiction de
la baaya mais il a également été réactif
sur l'harcèlement scolaire il a parlé
donc lancé une expérimentation sur
l'uniforme à l'école bref il a
revitalisé des des sujets d'autorité que
au auquel les Français semblent une
partie une grande partie des Français
semblent être sensible donc Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas besoin au fond des de de
de de ces de cette partie de la macronie
dite de de gauche euh qui euh peut-être
et avec le risque peut-être devienne se
constiue en sorte de frondeur pour la
fin du quinquena et on verra aussi dans
quelle mesure la la la gauche hor nupè
sera capable de pouvoir finalement
réagir les attirer et peut-être
construire aussi un une nouvelle force
politique avec eux à Monot Quentin oui
on peut se dire aussi que ce remignement
c'est justement un acte d'autorité du
chef de l'État pour punir aussi ces
frondeurs qu'on avait vu lors du projet
de loi immigration et peut-être qu'il a
vraiment pas du tout supporté ce qui
s'est passé au mois de décembre cette
crise où il a fallu qu'il fasse venir à
l'Élysée les chefs de sa majorité pour
se mettre d'accord au moment du vote des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire peut-être que voilà lui qui
avait été très marqué par ses frondeurs
sous le quinquenade François Hollande se
dit il faut absolument que tout de suite
on fasse table rase de cette voilà
volonté l'ile gauche de s'émanciper en
étant comme cela assez assez ferme lors
de ce remanement ouais oui mais il y a
une différence fondamentale quand même
avec l'époque de François Hollande c'est
que François Hollande avait une majorité
absolue et que par ailleurs il y avait
quelque chose qui s'appelait le Parti
socialiste or un parti comme le Parti
socialiste c'est autre chose que
Renaissance un parti un parti comme le
Parti socialiste c'est un parti dans
lequel bah vous êtes entré à 20 ans vous
avez fait votre cursusorum dans les dans
les collectivité territoriale vous
arrivez à l'Assemblée il y a une charge
sentimentale or si vous regardez 2017 et
la la dernière législature 2017-222 vous
avez une quarantaine de députés qui se
sont carapatés dans d'autres groupes qui
se sont restructurés dans d'autres
groupes parce qu'en réalité et bien il y
a pas d'attachement sentimental au
groupe naissance donc là vous avez des
députés qui demain qui plus qu'un
président qui ne peut pas se représenter
pourrait très bien décider de faire
bande à part or là quand vous avez déjà
une majorité relative si vous la
réduisez encore gouverner va être très
compliqué le Paris à court terme
peut-être payant à long terme il y a
quand même encore 3 ans et demi à tenir
légiférer risque d'être de plus en plus
difficile pour Emmanuel Macron et pour
Gabriel Atal et potentiellement le
successeur de Gabriel Atal parce que
avec cette majorité aujourd'hui
réellement fracturé et bien vous allez
va falloir sortir les tonnes de col le
jour où vous allez faire passer un
projet de loi et rapidement pour
terminer Michel il risque de se
compliquer la tâche au Parlement parce
que parmi les sortants il y en a qui
vont revenir à l'Assemblée à commencé
par ellisabeth B est-ce qu'il y a un
risque de frond et de groupe à part en
tout cas il y a un risque de je dirais
de au moins de d'opposition feutrée et
peut-être après de plus en non plus
affirmer et vous avez raison de de
souligner une fois qu'on aura dit à
l'envie quemanuel que pardon que Gabriel
Atal est un jeune garçon qu'il est plein
d'Allan et que il a composé une équipe
avec lui de personnalités surprenant il
faudra aussi gouverner il faudra être
capable de faire passer des mesures il
faut être capable d'insuffler une
méthode la sienne à des poids lourds qui
souvent le regarde un peu d'un air
gognard il devra s'imposer comme étant
aussi un chef d'équipe et surtout il a
martelé hier pas pour rien sur TF1
obtenir des résultats pour les Français
parce que c'est quand même la seule
chose qui va les intéresser
son qui sont assez indifférent à sa
nomination et on suivra évidemment tout
ça c'est vendredi veille de weekend on
vous emmène découvrir notre patrimoine
et nos tradition le chantier de
Notre-Dame de Paris se poursuit des
dizaines d'artisans travaillent pour
assurer la réouverture de l'édifice le 8
décembre prochain parmi eux l'entreprise
Bastia une PME familiale qui fabrique
les futures chaises de l'édifice
religieux Cécile Siou nous emmène à leur
rencontre dans les
noble et un style moderne et épuré voici
la nouvelle chaise de Notre-Dame un
modèle fabriqué ici dans cette PME
familiale des Landes l'entreprise Bastia
Sylvain Petitfils du fondateur a juste
les derniers détails sur des prototypes
ces ch vont être on va travailler
notamment sur les finition qui son
encore en cours de validation et du coup
vont aller dans notreame test avant de
lancer la production ces derniers il a
dû réorganiser son atelier la commande
est prestigieuse et ambitieuse 1500
chaises identiques haut de gamme à livré
avant octobre 2024 la chaise avait trois
contraintes bon déjà elle devait être en
bois euh
essement du chîn voilà pour comme ça ça
rappelit la charpente de Notre-Dame et
ensuite elle va être
empilable et attachable empilable parce
que les chaises vont être bougées vont
être bougé assez régulièrement voilà
selon les configurations et les
cérémonies qui peut y avoir et ensuite
elles doivent être attachables c'est à
partir de ces palettes de chaînne massif
français que se fait la découpe des
éléments une fois que les pièces sont
faites on va les monter donc là par un
système de avec de la colle un système
de Tenon de cheville de mortess voilà
donc on assemble toute la chaise de
manière à ce qu'on la régidifie voilà et
ensuite on refait une phase de ponage de
manière à la préparer pour la phase de
finition les derniers détails sont
finalisés dans cet atelier où le père de
Sylvain s'affaire
son bien voilà et on est en train de
bien glacer le bois avant de recevoir
lesteintte et les produits de finition
un dernier ponçage pour peaufiner le
bois avant de le peindre la version
finale a été choisie fin décembre père
et fils sont allés à Paris dans la nef
de Notre-Dame tester trois exemplaires
plus ou moins teintés et ont choisi la
version finale c'est exactement ce
produit là qu'on va retrouver à
NotreDame à peut-être un petit poil de
teinte près mais complètement
insignifiant une consération un coup de
projecteur pour Alain il avait lui-même
hérité de la menuiserie familiale de son
père évidment que quand j'ai annoncé la
nouvelle à mon père bon voilà les ou à
mes parents parce que les deux sont là
et les deux ont travaillé dans
l'entreprise et donc les larmes sont
vite monté aux yeux on m'a évidemment
dit fait attention c'est un peu grand
voilà mais c'est normal mais quoi qu'il
en soit ils sont très fiers et moi très
fier d'intégrer la génération d'après
sur ce projet là Pier aussi de Silvin
pour son père il y a 10 ans face à une
crise du mobilier concurrencée par les
productions chinoises il a fait le choix
du savoir-faire et du haut de gamme un
choix aujourd'hui
récompensé récupéré et voilà pour ce
reportage on vaarler du remanement
Quentin puisque c'est à la une de la
presse régionale
salut
[Musique]
et Quentin le romaniimement fait la Une
de très nombreux titres ce matin oui qui
a dit que les Français ne
s'intéressaient pas à la question du
remagnement la presse quotidienne
régionale effectivent est très curieuse
en tout cas ce matin selon l'ardenis à
charleseville mère Gabriel Atal muscle
le jeu avec cette équipe un casting très
politique he ajoute le titre Ouest
France est plus duubitatif avec un
remanimement à minima la voie du Nord
qui résume du classique et la surprise
du chef un ramement avec quelques
surprises selon Nice ce matin cette idée
d'un coup politique avec la nomination
de Rachid hadti elle revient donc
largement et la nomination de Rachid
hadti participe à faire pencher le
gouvernement à droite c'est ce qu'on
disait effectivement la barre à droite
résume ainsi l'Alsace avec la photo de
la nouvelle ministre de la Culture même
idée avec la Charente Libre Atal qui
sert à droite et enfin cette troisème
expression sa penche à droite pour la
Nouvelle République à tour et donc donc
la surprise du chef c'est Rachid adti et
elle seule elle fait la Une de plusieurs
titres je vous le disais ces journaux
qui rappelle sa proximité avec Nicolas
Sarkozi c'est peut-être aussi he bien
sûr une des explications à cette entrée
au gouvernement le Courrier Picard qui
rappelle les propos de Rachid hadti en
juin 2021 vous en parliez tout à l'heure
en marche c'est quoi c'est des traîtres
de gauche et des traîtres de droite la
nouvelle ministre est connue aussi pour
son Fran parler on peut le dire ça
promet pour les prochains mois dans le
contexte aussi de cette mise en examen
c'est ce que rappelle aussi ces journaux
depuis juillet 2021 pour trafic
d'influence passif dans une enquête sur
des contrats d'une filiale de Renault
Nissan le parquet d'ailleurs qui doit
rendre ses réquisitions très
prochainement c'est ce que rappelle par
exemple le Courrier Picard Catherine
varain entre également au gouvernement
oui le journal de reince l'Union qui
bien sûr fait sa Une sur ce sur cette
entrée on comprend les journaux he de
ces départements où ces personnalités
sont très connues et bien s'intéresse
particulièrement au sujet puisqu'on
rappelle que Catherine Vautrin était
jusqu'à hier la présidente de la
métropole de reince le titre rappelle
aussi son super ministère un super
ministre dans dans les pages intérieures
la ministre est d'ailleurs interview
c'est un énorme honneur réagit-elle dans
le journal elle dit vouloir agir sur les
sujets du quotidien des Français et on
termine avec le courer de l'Ouest voilà
exactement la même chose au Courrier de
l'Ouest même chose que pour reins
puisque ils font leur titre sur
Christophe Béchu l'ancien maire d'Anger
qui est reconduit et donc le Courrier de
l'Ouest qui en parle merci beaucoup
merci conttin merci Benjamin Morel merci
Mel d'avoir été avec nous pour n parler
de ce remement merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi et on se retrouve bien
évidemment lundi on vous souhaite un
très bon
weekend